the kaiapoi south regeneration area of
approximately twenty eight hectares lies
between raven key and hilton street just
east of the town center and runs
parallel to the kaiapoi river and then
turning in a southerly direction along
courtney drive is bounded by the kaikan
ooey stream and the courtney stream from
just south of rotana fer if you're
traveling south along hilton street on
your left hand side the area has been
identified as suitable for business use
which could include vehicle parking or
yard based activities such as a plant
nursery or a car sales yard continuing
south along hilton street towards
courtney drive this has been identified
as a heritage and Myung a chi area
recognizing the cultural ecological and
amenity significance there is a proposal
which the council supports for joint
management of the area with NATO it
could be a couple of smaller strips
suitable for recreation and acting as
ecological linkage leading through the
m'hir KY area from hilton street towards
the kaiapoi river and further south
leading from courtney drive to and
alongside ncf park over on the
right-hand side of hilton street this
area has been identified as suitable for
rural uses however that would exclude
intensive farming further south and
alongside wider place would be a
suitable area for a new neighborhood
park please note that there are two
different roading options being
considered in the kaiapoi south area
details of these can be found on the
council website or at redzone planned
nzd we'd like your comments on these
regeneration area proposals for full
details of all the options outlined in
let's plan or to comment on the plan
visit the council website at Waimakariri
govt TN z or red zone planned NZ or pick
up a copy of the plan from any council
server center or library